le sel est devenu le repère d'une
panoplie de groupes terroristes et de
bandits
qui se disputent les trafics de drogue
d'armes et de migrants nigériens ont
appris à vivre avec les risques
d'attentats et de kidnapping il aurait
accouché d'un gazon dont l'appel mais
n'a pour lui dit il est dans l'avion
permet les comptes un ils crient nous
pouvons afflux d'avions là on a fait
douter
niamey la capitale du niger accueille
depuis deux ans les rencontres
internationales du rire des humoristes
de plusieurs pays d'afrique et y
participent dont le rapide vie au
burkina faso où l'industrie du stand-up
connect explose d'humour appelé dessus
c'est un mot les skippers en plus une
salle de 4000 places soit versée la même
ia papote
mais c'est comme ça les guys les gens
ont besoin de se déstresser des sourires
parce que avec l'attak déjà 10 au
burkina tu vois les gens n'ont plus la
tête d'aller écouter de la musique
il veut quelqu'un qui va les faire rire
pour qu'ils oublient au ps ceci quoi
oublier les soucis est devenu un art que
les nigériens pratiques comme des
virtuoses la guerre menée dans le nord
du pays n'est pas visible à niamey qui
s'est développée comme jamais depuis
cinq ans édifice et infrastructures
modernes
beaucoup de routes pavées et plus
sécuritaire et ceinture de sécurité il
est qu'est-ce que deux motos sont
désormais obligatoires
alors êtes vous quand tu vois quelqu'un
qui porte tout le temps un casque c'est
juste parce que la personne a piqué des
crédits un peu partout dans la ville
donc
alliant mezel impossible tout le monde a
des crédits un peu partout parce que nos
coups de casque sur la tête ou assez
pour tout à l'heure iront ainsi
l'instigateur des rencontres durée au
niger un pays où le stand de n'existait
pas encore il y à peine deux ans il fait
donc venir des venues d'ailleurs
alors bon soir des revues comme moussa
petit sergent le burkinabé s'est fait
connaître par le mans du rire une
émission de la chaîne française canal
plus souvent très tard dans la nuit
avant bouaida métal chérie tu sais moi
je n'arrive pas à dormir je vais
entendre ta voix comme si ma voix et un
somnifère
humour afrique et est populaire en
europe
cette émission qui ne présente que des
talents africains et diffusé à 28
dimanche soir une heure de grande écoute
des français d'ici qui viennent me voir
qu'ils connaissent pas du tout l'afrique
et qui me disent à travers votre
spectacle
j'ai eu un déclic ça a changé en tout
cas mon regard par rapport à l'afrique
laisser les véhicules qui passent plus
le contrôle technique en france qui
polluent l'atmosphère
allez zou on ne les envoie ici parce que
nous sommes une poubelle bio chez nous
au burkina est un artiste qui fait un
travail remarquable avec ça ils
occupaient toute cette vieille ferraille
que la france nous envoie et avec ça ils
fabriquent des objets d'art qui le vend
aux touristes français et ça le pas à la
france
comédien formé au théâtre moussa est
devenu humoriste pour changer le monde
une blague à la fois enfin de l'humour
c'est aussi un engagement que quelques
temps déjà mais à partir de nos tu
penses tu prends la parole en public
c'est parce que quelque part tu as une
rage c'est parce que quelque part tu as
quelque chose à dire
donc tu t'engages le niger est le
quatrième pays exportateur d'uranium au
monde au monde
mais comme il tient à rester parmi les
pays pauvres pour nous emmerder
il laisse le soin aux entreprises
étrangères devenue extrait cet uranium
est de fixer elles mêmes les plus
d'achats ciel malhonnête
oui c'est vrai que nous aussi on butine
ont fait ça avec l'or et le coton mais
c'est pas parler vous pouvez aider
l'occident se développer rapidement afin
qu'ils puissent mieux nous aider
les relations entre riches et pauvres
entre africains et occidentaux
des thèmes dominants cameraman filme moi
s'il te plaît tu me vois bien
oh là là j'ai fait travailler plein jo
le rapide fait beaucoup rire en se
moquant des blancs les réglages quoi tu
vois quel que soit le vega déjà ils s'en
foutent quoi tu vois les humoristes
afrique et semble avoir peu de tables
aurait de tout même des abus de la
religion des violences faites aux femmes
les mêmes les monnaies et les femmes
[Musique]
ouais
l'ivoirien par contre ne touche pas à la
politique
la guerre qui a déchiré son pays a
laissé des marques
je ne peux pas oublier parce que j'ai
perdu des amis de d'un moment c'est que
celle mais l'effet sauty jallet prend
des armes comme mes amies de sa m
attache à la maison pour le paquet j
sont donc je parle pas de la politique
de mes sketches c'est trop dangereux
très dangereux parce que souvent en
voulant bien faire
tu fais mal et pourtant si tu as mal
fait il n'ya pas des paroles des dents
ils vont et tabassé où l'on paie cash et
à callière complètement ces jeunes
portent en eux les cicatrices de
l'esclavagé et du colonialisme les
blessures d'un présent encore violent
mais il souhaite regarder en avant
ok d'accord on entendu en fait une
maîtrise d'histoire mais concrètement
qu'est ce que tu proposes d'abord sera
acceptée l'histoire c'est la certitude
ce qui s'est passé mais aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que nous on fait pour changer
les choses
comment est-ce que nous maintenant on
met nos efforts en ce sens pour mais ce
que chacun peut arriver à respecter
l'autre et comment est-ce qu'on peut
arriver
à vivre ensemble et à proposer quelque
chose de meilleur à mes enfants qui vont
arriver demain
[Musique]